after 170 days in Space the four
astronauts of the SpaceX crew Dragon
freedom undocked from the International
Space Station and embarked on their
five-hour return journey to Earth
bad weather across Florida had caused a
one-day delay to the homecoming of NASA
astronauts Jessica Watkins Bob Heinz
kachell Lindgren and the European space
agencies Samantha christopheretti
SpaceX and NASA gave the all clear
Friday with a Splashdown sight near the
coast of Jacksonville so we are getting
our very first views there from the
wb-57 of the capsule as it re-enters the
Earth's atmosphere Mission Control
watched with baited breath as Dragon
Freedom entered the most critical six
minutes of the trip home when
temperatures outside reached nearly 2
000 degrees Celsius making
Communications impossible
Freedom SpaceX Comcheck
hey thanks for coming through three
kilometers
copy and concurred the re-entry was
Flawless brace for drug window
s
two small parachutes deployed slowing
The Descent to 560 kilometers per hour
and one minute later four bigger shoots
gradually slowed The Vessel to a gentle
25 kilometers per hour
foreign
[Music]
ending with Splashdown at 4 55 PM local
time
Swiss spacex's fourth successful
astronaut Mission transporting Crews to
and from the International Space Station
for NASA
and awaiting recovery vessel lifted
Dragon Freedom aboard a doctor was the
first to Welcome Home crew 4 in person
and Mission pilot hides was the first to
emerge behind him came the three other
astronauts including Watkins the first
black woman to complete a long-term
space flight
more medical checks await them then a
trip to Houston where they'll be
reunited with family the astronauts said
they look forward to a cold drink with
ice a shower and reveling in the nature
of planet Earth
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera